there's no shortage of gut churning
horror films on Netflix but a new
offering has audiences covering their
mouths clutching their stomachs and even
getting sick it's safe to say the
perfection is unlike any horror film
you've ever seen before on Netflix or
anywhere else but before we get too deep
into the nitty gritty
please note major spoilers ahead the
perfection stars allison williams and
logan browning as Charlotte and Lizzy -
cello prodigies who study at the
prestigious music school back off the
film centers around Charlotte's return
to back off after taking a leave of
absence to look after her ailing mother
she reconnects with her mentors and soon
meets the talented musician who replaced
her when she left that musician is Lizzy
I'm sorry am I the luckiest man in the
world I don't even drink and I feel
dizzy drunk like two most perfect
students together based on the film's
title and storyline it's easy to assume
the perfection will be a dark tale of
jealousy and one-upmanship much like
Darren Aronofsky's 2010 psychological
thriller Black Swan or the classic 1950
melodrama All About Eve but then after
the first of many plot twists you might
mistake the perfection for a ghoulish
outbreak drama was happening
you're armed but the perfection is
actually far more complex than that and
the end result has a few far more
grotesque moments if Twitter can be
believed the film's occasional grisly
moments and insane ending are making
viewers physically ill one Twitter user
complained I haven't seen the whole
thing but I watched some scenes from the
perfection on Netflix and it is
literally making me feel sick another
viewer tweeted the perfection on Netflix
is sick in a bad way ugh
my body can't move and I feel like
puking and yet another viewer totally
agreed with that assessment just got
done eating while watching the
perfection on Netflix and I think I'm
going to puke but that's not to say it's
a bad film by any stretch of the
imagination plenty of people thought the
perfection was a gripping and original
horror movie one Twitter user
breathlessly summed up her feelings by
writing the film is sick twisted cunning
beautifully made creepy evil scary funny
tragic all at the same time what a
psychological horror thriller while many
viewers found it grueling to watch the
perfection it reportedly wasn't the
easiest film to make either in one
particularly gnarly scene Lizzie has a
panic attack after vomiting maggots and
yellow bile all over a bus window
director Richard Shepherd told Bloody
Disgusting that that scene proved to be
rather challenging it was tough to edit
because Logan is yelling and freaking
out so much just looking at takes was
exhausting but I knew if we could get
the sequence to work it would be an
amazing bit of moviemaking
well all that hard work certainly paid
off viewers are obviously totally
freaked out by the perfection which is
certified fresh on Rotten Tomatoes many
reviewers have praised the film with
Katie Walsh of the Los Angeles Times
claiming the wild ride in store is both
supremely disturbing and unpredictable
but rendered with such care skill and
sheer glee it's utterly divine the ad
clubs Katy Rice ultimately gave the film
a b-minus but also noted the perfection
takes deep fetishistic satisfaction in
pushing the envelope then pushing it
some more building in seductive Fitz and
shocking starts to an orgy astok
see of cinematic access the film
definitely isn't for anyone with a
sensitive stomach but if you're looking
for an original horror thriller go ahead
and check out the perfection just be
sure to have a barf bag at the ready and
don't say we didn't warn you
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]